IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net speaks out against false
allegations leveled at him after
announcing potential Senate run I will
not stop I will not give up on Wednesday
Tim Ballard released a statement
addressing allegations leveled against
him following his announcement that he
was running for the senate in Utah
Ballard read from a press release from
his nonprofit the spear fund which read
rescuing kids and fighting child
trafficking is an ugly and dark business
especially when as the result of my work
for more than 20 years we continue to
expose members of the powerful
well-funded child trafficking cartels
evil pedophiles will stop at nothing and
they have allies in government in the
media in big corporations and even in
public institutions they will continue
to lie about an attempt to destroy my
good name and they will never stop
Ballard said he wanted to let everyone
know that I I and our vast Army of
supporters will likewise never stop we
will keep fighting for the vulnerable
all over the globe and we know that the
truth will always Prevail I am a
faithful member in good standing in the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints I believe in Jesus Christ the
holy scriptures and I believe in our
faith with my whole heart that will
never change Ballard said that it has
been alleged that an anonymous LDS
spokesperson issued a statement about me
through a tabloid that is often hostile
to people of Faith further my church is
not publicly verified its authenticity
so uh we have this other story from the
post millennial Utah da closed criminal
investigation into operation Underground
Railroad Tim Ballard in March they false
allegations what do you think is going
to happen if you're if you're hunting
down trafficking
cartels yeah they're going to play dirty
to try and stop you the funny thing
about this the attacks against Russell
Brand the attacks against Julian Assange
and now get this Rudy
Giuliani oh that's just come on it's
just the only thing they have is they're
like how do we stop this guy just say he
groped some woman or something and it's
like okay I guess yeah we're at the
point where it's like dude like I was
saying earlier you come at Russell Brand
and we're like that's kind of weird
they're all coming after Russell Brand
but he does have that past that was his
thing he joked a lot about this stuff
you know he he there's a video Someone
posted where he's joking with a woman if
he can get on with her or her daughters
and she's like my daughters are 15 or
whatever he made some pretty crude jokes
and so you wonder man how responsible or
irresponsible was this guy but Tim
Ballard like a a a a Bible
thumping child trafficking uh hunt like
hunting what I'm sorry the least
credible allegations I've ever heard are
the ones against Tim Beller it's just
there's no way I'm I'm I just at this
point any they come out and claim that
Donald Trump did something it's just no
one's going to believe it they could
come out and say any they could come out
and say Andrew Tate was like abusing
women at this point and I'm just like
bro all of this stuff to be fair they
did come out and say that about Tate I'm
saying they could they could like make
crazier accusations at this point I'm
just like Andrew T could literally come
out and say those past videos you know
or all of him saying these things I'm
not going to believe any of it it's just
they they try every single person it's
the only thing they have yeah but the
thing is is that when Russell Brand he
was out in the public eye saying all of
these things and the media supported him
he was a hero of media that's the czy
thing right so the time in which all
these things were happening everybody
knew and hisat right his personality in
a lot of these shows was as that kind of
gutter snipe like
misogynistic uh you know guy so and he
was the hero it wasn't until he then
crossed over that he became the enemy
they're like you know we tried calling
everybody racists for a while and it
didn't really work so we upgraded to
white supremacist that's not really
working anymore let's just call them all
rapists there you go yeah and it's it's
you know sort of non false right you
can't prove or disprove something that
happened 15 20 years ago I I don't know
much about uh Tim Ballard but uh you
know Russell Brand I mean that was the
sort of character that he was playing
but sort of regardless of all of that
are are we saying that if you get
convicted of a crime you can't earn a
living anymore uh which obviously hasn't
been convicted or as far as I can tell
even uh legally charged with committing
any any of these crimes but it's almost
like a does the F does the punishment
fit the crime is this not cruel and
unusual punishment for yeah a you know
po baseless accusation and the craziest
part about that was the article that
came out in The Times They say like
these women didn't say anything until we
our reporters approached them and they
thought it was important to come out
because of the his new found prominence
as a dissident right-wing person so it's
like they're not even hiding anymore
they're literally saying because he is a
prominent dissident and because he
speaks out against the establishment
therefore here's the accusations that
were're making against him it's insane I
think that that's that's super important
that the fact that this is all coming
out is only because of the because of
his political stances this was perfect
this was this was perfectly fine no one
had an issue there was no problem for
what almost 20 years now MH that that
since it's happened same thing again we
we talked about Howard Stern earlier no
one has an issue with that and no one's
coming after Howard Stern because Howard
Stern is is pushing the party line he is
saying the politically correct positions
he has the proper allowable uh opinions
if you have a dissenting opinion there
are people that are going to go at go in
go into your history look for anything
they can come up with people love to
tell me I'm wrong or specifically like
lips pardon my French but like bad
liberals people that are terrible
liberals we are in a maist cultural
revolution in the United States right
now these are the things that were done
in Mau China in order for the Communist
Party to gain control they use the Red
Guard to intimidate people to accuse
people of all sorts of different in uh
improprieties and stuff this is what's
going on it's obviously it's not going
to look exactly the same as in China you
know 70 or 60 years ago but a lot of the
same tactics are being used of the same
shaming the same trying to ostracize
people kick them out of polite Society
kick take their ability to to provide
for their families and stuff all of that
stuff is happening right now what my
question too is let's apply this same
logic Terror read that's all I got to
say Terror read Joe Biden's got to be
banned from YouTube yep no more White
House videos on YouTube because Joe
Biden you know he he did those awful
shut the Clinton Foundation down shut it
down yeah that would only be fair Bill
Clinton can't take a dime from anybody
but that's what it is and it's it's the
great reset and it's the uh the
stakeholder capitalism is what it is
where they have companies I mean it's we
said the great reset should be called
like something like the great
consolidation or the the great
coagulation right it's it's uh companies
and government acting seemingly
independently but in perfect uh
coordination with one another to carry
these things out so I mean this is it's
it's a cultural revolution but it's
worldwide and it's being orchestrated
from it's being orchestrated from a
central power but also like we really
are in this in this phase where they all
just sort of know and there doesn't
necessarily have to be some sort of
conspiracy behind the scenes where
they're secretly communicating with one
another they all just sort of know I
mean you know in the old days you'd have
like a false flag attack you'd have to
control the media and you have to have
the police on your side and every you
know certain people in key positions now
they just sort of do it and the media
knows okay here's the narrative that I'm
going along with and don't investigate
it too much or else you might find out
how fake it is it's because it's an
ideology you don't have to have you you
can have Christians from different parts
of the world that have never met each
other and they're still going to be able
to tell you how Christianity works you
can have Muslims from different parts of
the world that have never met each other
they're still going to be able to tell
you how Islam works it's the same thing
with this with this type of mentality
it's an ideology and so it doesn't
matter if the people are read into the
newest Cutting Edge uh stuff in fact
sometimes they make errors like when uh
whim whim was a bad bad one but when
kenty Brown Jackson was uh yeah the the
when she was having her hearing and she
said I'm not a biologist like that was
the wrong answer not she was saying
gender was biology exactly she should it
should have been uh I forget I'm not a
gender theorist yeah that it should have
been gender theorist that would have
been the correct one she actually made
an error according to the theory but
like Tim said she should have said she's
a gender theorist to be able to to
explain that but you don't have to know
The Cutting Edge because they'll cover
for you if you make an error doesn't
matter you're on you have the right
politics you're you're going for the
right side so we'll go ahead and we'll
will brush the the M step under the rug
and simply put if you are living your
life living your career of hunting down
trafficking cartels the the the easiest
and most obviously way to stop you is to
accuse you is to try and do something
like this bunk
allegations but it's but it's I mean
look how long until Oliver Anthony gets
falsely
accused Tik Tock I mean he's trying real
hard not to be super political despite
the fact that his songs are very
political and anti-establishment which
is anti-left inherently it's only a
matter of time I guess and and you know
the the real issue is what they don't
want you to do is have your own platform
to be able to defend yourself I mean
it's the same thing they uh you know did
with with Alex Jones right they accuse
him of things and then remove him from
social media so he can't actually argue
back so the only narrative that's
allowed to be proliferated is their
narrative so they want and and the way
that the specifically like the online uh
safety act in the UK they want the comp
compies and the platforms themselves to
preemptively take action on content
that's posted so the way it is now if
the government issues a request and then
retroactively you go you go in and
remove it they want the companies to
actually take that burden on and remove
posts themselves preemptively before the
government has to get involved so that's
where the stakeholder capitalism comes
in where the corporations are actually
taking on that burden and if they don't
then the corporations are the ones being
uh punished by the uh by the government
so they want to uh create a situation
where they can make accusations and the
accused has no ability to respond in a
in a mainstream fashion thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net